اثار مقطع فيديو على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعيه تعاطفا واسعا مع طفله يمنيه
وهي تنهار باكيه وتشتكي بعدما ان اكلت قطه
عصافيرها وظهرت الطفله التي تدعى فطوم
لاحقا بفيديو اخر وهي في قمه فرحتها عندما
اهداها شاب مجموعه من الهدايا وعصافير
جديده عوضا عن التي اكلتها القطه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
العصفوره تحط فطوم
البسه اكل العصفوره تحط فطوم فطوم
[موسيقى]
في مشهد يحبس الانفاس فاجا اسد ضخم مجموعه
من السياح اثناء تقييمهم في محميه طبيعيه
في جنوب افريقيا واظهر الفيديو الاسد وهو
يقترب منهم وطلب مسؤول المنطقه من السياح
ان يتملكوا اعصابهم ويظل هادئين ويبدو ان
التعليمات التعليمات كانت صحيحه ودقيقه
اذا انصرف الاسد بهدوء
[موسيقى]
نقي مقطع فيديو متداول على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي تعاطفا كبيرا لفرحه طفله سعوديه
مصابه بمتلازمه داون عندما سمعت تسجيلا
صوتيا لاختها الكبرى وهي تبارك لها
بالنجاح
[موسيقى]
اليوم انا راح ابارك الاجمل بنت بالدنيا
الجميله رزان اختي وحبيبتي وعيوني كلها
رزان الف الف الف مبروك النجاح انا بدور
اختك احبك كثير فوق ما تتخيلين ويا رب ان
شاء الله اشوفك من نجاح النجاح وباعلى
المراتب
واقول لك واقول لكل صديقاتك الجميلات
واصدقائك الجميلين الف مبروك للجميع
النجاح
[موسيقى]
اثار مقطع فيديو على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي اعجابا كبيرا لمدرس وهو يخفف عن
الطلاب حراره الجو اثناء اداء الامتحان في
احدى المدارس في العراق ووصف بعض الناشطين
على مواقع التواصل التصرف المعلم
بالانساني والابوي
[موسيقى]
المعلمه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
كان هذا كل شيء اليوم لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات